la colonne britannique veut protéger les
victimes de s'extorsion et de partage
non consentis d'images intimes c'est un
projet de loi qui est assez novateur
notamment dans la façon de traiter les
plaintes oui accéléré certainement le
processus judiciaire alors vous allez
voir sur les images la procureur général
de la Colombie-Britannique il y a la
fête cette annonce aux côtés d'une femme
qu'on a appris à connaître dans des
circonstances tragiques c'est à dire la
mère de mandata de la jeune fille de 15
ans la qui s'était enlevé la vie en 2012
après avoir subi une longue campagne de
chantage alors la province la
Colombie-Britannique veut mettre sur
pied le premier tribunal en ligne du
Canada les victimes pourraient donc
pourront dénoncer des cas de s'extorsion
ou de partage d'image intime non
consentis par le biais de ce tribunal en
ligne et la procureur de la province dit
que ça permet notamment de lever la
barrière chez certains enfants certains
jeunes qui ne veulent pas en parler à
leurs parents mais ce serait donc une
façon d'aller dénoncer des cas on va
entendre la procureur général de la
Colombie Britannique suivie de Madame
Todd
il monte c'est ce qu'on dit en flèche
même les signalements de cas de
s'extorsion qui concerne des adolescents
augmentées de 56%, 56% c'est beaucoup la
demeure ça août 2022 et d'ailleurs vous
allez entendre une mise en garde très
très sentie de la part du porte-parole
du Centre canadien de protection de
l'enfance René Morin
il faut surtout mais alors là surtout ne
pas faire ce qui nous est demandé vous
êtes en présence d'un sextor cœur qui
vous demande d'autres images intimes
c'est non il va utiliser toutes sortes
de moyens pour vous convaincre sinon il
va vous demander de l'argent c'est non
parce que toutes les analyses qu'on a pu
faire et tous les témoignages qu'on a pu
recueillir auprès de victimes le
montrent clairement si vous leur donnez
ce qu'ils veulent ils vont vous en
demander plus
et c'est clair c'est de la violence
sexuelle c'est possible de poursuites le
message c'est celui-là que veut faire
passer la Colombie Britannique on vous
en parlait mais c'est très intéressant
ce projet de loi c'est très novateur en
Colombie-Britannique c'est un projet de
loi pour protéger les victimes de sexe
torsion et de partage non consentis
d'images intimes en ligne les victimes
pourront maintenant dénoncer ces actes
d'un tout dans un tout premier tribunal
en ligne au pays nous allons en discuter
avec Cathy et trou qui est la directrice
générale du centre cyber aide une
organisation sans but lucrative qui
justement formule de l'aide et des
conseils comme ça madame je peux vous
demander juste pour qu'on se comprenne
tout le monde juste l'expression
s'extorsion qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on entend par ce mot-là pour être sûr
que tout le monde on soit sur la même
page
de la s'extorsion c'est à dire d'aller
chercher des bénéfices avec des photos
ou des images non consenties là de
jeunes ou d'adultes donc c'est d'aller
chercher je vous donne un exemple chez
des adultes et peut avoir des marines
des gens mariés qui se font avoir en
allant sur un site en partageant des
photos intimes en pensant que c'est une
personne qui peuvent le faire puis
finalement ils reçoivent des menaces si
de divulgation de la vidéo de la photo
s'il ne donne pas de l'argent donc c'est
vraiment un lien avec des bénéfices la
secteur de la sextorsion bon ok alors
c'est le jeu de mots entre sexe et
extorsion alors mais là alors vous avez
eu sans doute eu la chance de le voir en
tout cas ou de comprendre le principe
qui anime le projet de loi en Colombie
Britannique c'est c'est qu'est-ce qui
vous fascine le fait que c'est un
tribunal en ligne ça veut dire que on
peut agir assez discrètement chez soi on
remplit un formulaire ça doit être tout
un avantage c'est un avant-garde ça
oui en même temps j'ai un petit bémol
puis je dois juste vous dire que c'est
une idée vraiment géniale dans un
deuxième temps cette idée là est pour
aussi ce que j'ai lu c'est que les
enfants ne sont pas obligés d'en parler
à leurs parents s'ils ne se sentent pas
capable donc d'aller aussi dire
malheureusement je me suis fait avoir ou
peu importe sauf que nous on prend
vraiment la communication entre les
parents et les enfants donc le plan a ce
serait l'éducation près des parents la
façon qui réagisse quand le jeune leur
partage aussi et qui comprennent bien
que souvent le partage de photos intimes
n'est pas mal intentionné donc est-ce
que c'est correct pour vous vous me
voyez bien
ok excusez-moi c'est le système que j'ai
fait à la maison c'est pas finalement
excusez-moi donc c'est ça c'est ce
serait comme le plan a le plan a ce
serait de d'éduquer les parents
d'informer les jeunes de sensibiliser la
population sur le fait parfait je suis
encore désolé sur le fait que
ça fait partie du développement cognitif
sexuel de désirer de se montrer puis
finalement ils se font avoir donc il y a
ça le plan B serait oui d'avoir un
endroit aussi pour pouvoir
dénoncer quelqu'un ou dire on peut tu
retirer les photos que malheureusement
j'ai fait que j'ai produite puis je veux
plus le faire ça c'est vraiment génial
ce qui ont fait un Colombie Britannique
puis j'aimerais bien que ce soit fait
aussi
ici au Québec bon êtes-vous confronté
régulièrement ce genre de situation là
des jeunes ou des moins jeunes aussi là
qui se trouve coincé avec des photos
intimes qui sont en circulation et qu'on
aimerait bien voir disparaître
c'est la plupart c'est ça il y a des
contextes de comme on parle de
s'extorsion c'est que les gens peuvent
obliger mais dans les écoles dans les
organismes communautaires c'est bien
plus souvent c'est mon choix c'est ma
blonde j'ai le droit je lui en envoie
finalement il y a de la chicane il y a
de la jalousie et là les photos sont
partagées c'est plus comme ça c'est dans
des comportements adolescents pour les
adultes
il y en entendre assez parlé quand même
de pas le faire mais encore là la
sexualité c'est quelque chose qui est
normal entre guillemets puis tant que ce
sera pas clair dans pour tout le monde
le sait que ce soit les jeunes les
parents les adultes que ça peut rester
sur le web et que ça peut nuire à la
réputation puis que même ça peut causer
plusieurs
domaines plusieurs conséquences bien là
c'est certain que il va arriver encore
des choses comme ça là faut rester je
comprends bien vigilant puis en tout cas
suivre ça de près c'est intéressant
voici d'autres gouvernements ou d'autres
organisations vont vont emboîter le pas
parce qu'il y a des pistes de solution
en tout cas qui vont peut-être voir la
lumière au bout du tunnel merci beaucoup
madame au revoir merci bonne journée au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI